en général Monsieur le Chef de Service
mes chers collègues euh dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 nous accueillons aujourd'hui
Monsieur Stéphane bouillon bien connu
dans cette commission secrétaire général
de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale pour l'entendre sur les
crédits du programme 129 relatif à la
coordination des politiques de défense
et de sécurité nationale de
cybersécurité et de lutte contre les
menaces hybrides je vous remercie
d'ailleurs vot de votre présence parce
que j'ai cru comprendre que
habituellement à cette heure-là il y
avait des conseils de défense qui compte
tenu de la actualités ont déjà eu lieu
cette semaine et donc ce qui a fait que
vous avez pu vous libérer pour venir
nous nous nous nous pour venir être
auditionn ici vous êtes accompagné donc
du général de brigade aérienne Emmanuel
néelin directeur adjoint de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité des systèmes
d'information la fameuse Ancy et de Marc
Antoine Briant chef du service de
vigilance des protections contre les
ingérences numériques étrangères viginum
et je soulligne que depuis votre
audition de l'année dernière
l'état-major qui vous entoure a été
entièrement renouvelé puisque monsieur
Vincent Strubel représenté aujourd'hui
par le général néelin a remplacé
Guillaume Poupard à la tête de l'ancy en
début d'année et plus récemment monsieur
Briant a pris la relève de Gabriel
Ferriol s'agissant de viginum qui a été
créé il y a seulement 2 ans il s'agit
donc de la première occasion ici de
dresser un premier bilan de son action
dans un domaine celui de la lutte contre
les ingérences étrangères en matière de
manipulation de l'information que le
Président de la République a érigé en
priorité stratégique dans la revue
nationale stratégique et dont on voit
aujourd'hui encore un peu plus combien
elle a d'importance je ne cache pas que
ce que vous pourrez nous dire sur Vigin
nous intéresse évidemment
particulièrement et donc vous nous direz
aussi Monsieur le Secrétaire général
comment vous entendez développer les
missions de lany pour faire face aux
menaces de cybersécurité qui concerne
notre sécurité nationale mais aussi
chaque citoyen de notre pays des
attaques très graves ont perturbé les
services publics des collectivités
territoriales des établissement de santé
je je pense qu'aucun d'entre nous ici
dans sa circonscription ne peut dire
qu'il n'a pas entendu parler d'une
attaque certainement des questions à
poser et notamment Olivier cadiic et
michaell valet qui sont reconduits dans
leur fonction de rapporteur du programme
129 je rappelle que cette audition porte
sur la cybersécurité et les menaces
hybrides compte tenu du contexte
sécuritaire il y aura peut-être
peut-être des questions en rapport avec
la menace terroriste mais je vous
laisserai évidemment juge d'y répondre
au regard de vos attributions monsieur
Monsieur le Secrétaire général Monsieur
le Directeur général avant de vous céder
la parole je rappelle que cette audition
est captée et donc retransmis sur le
site internet du Sénat en direct je vous
laisse la parole dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez et puis après on passera au au
rapporteurs et aux questions de des
collègues merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs pour la 4e fois
je suis heureux de vous retrouver et de
retrouver des sénateurs avec qui j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler tout au long de
ma carrière et et c'est à chaque fois un
vrai plaisir de de pouvoir vous
retrouver et venir vous rendre compte de
ce que nous faisons de ce que nous
préparons des des moyens dont nous
disposons et de la manière dont nous
essayons de faire face aux différentes
crises auxquelles est est confronté
notre pays et vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président ces crises sont
nombreuses et se sont encore accrues ces
jours derniers puisque au dernier
conseil de vendredi nous avons proposé à
la première ministre de passer en
urgence attentat et et donc c'est ce qui
a été décidé et c'est ce qui explique
l'ensemble des mesures que connaît
aujourd'hui notre pays évidemment je
pourrais y revenir si vous vous le
permettez je commencerai d'abord par
vous présenter succintement notre projet
de budget qui vous sera soumis pour
2024 le SGDSN représente le plus du
tiers des crédits totaux de la mission
Direction de l'action du gouvernement
c'est-àdire que vraiment nous sommes les
les gros consommateurs le BOP SGDSN
représente 40 % des crédits du programme
36 % de ses crédits T2 43 % des crédit
hors T2 et pour cette année
2024 nous vous proposons un budget de
consolidation qui progressera donc
encore de 4,8 % en AE et de 11,8 % en CP
par rapport à 23 ce qui nous fera
363,5 million d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et
362,9 en crédit de paiement évidemment
comme d'habitude il y a le tiers de ce
budget qui est constitué par des
dépenses de masse salariale mais il y a
aussi donc les 2 tiers en dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'investissement avec
des augmentations de coût
d'électricité aussi des augmentations de
dépenses pour les crédits de travaux
interministériels et puis également une
augmentation des moyens de viginium qui
est en train de monter en puissance et
bien sûr une augmentation des moyens de
lanc notamment pour leur permettre de
faire face à la préparation des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 notre schéma d'emploi
trigénal 2024 2027 est est respecté donc
nous aurons euh si vous le décidez 56
ETP supplémentaires en 2024 40 au profit
de l'ancy 10 au profit de l'osic
l'opérateur des
services classifié qui est confronté
évidemment à une hausse de charge avec
l'ensemble du matériel qui est destiné
au communication
intergouvernementale mais aussi
interadministration et qui sont donc
protégés contre les ingérances
étrangères et celle-ci se multiplie et
puis il y aura aussi des emplois
supplémentaires pour logic par ailleurs
vu inum récupérera 17 ETP par voie de
transfert 10 ETP provenant du ministère
de l'Intérieur et 7 ETP provenant du
ministère des armées ces emplois qui
étaient auparavant mis à disposition
vont être totalement intégrés dans les
dans le service ce qui lui permettra
d'une part de renouveler le caschant ses
effectifs et de compléter les les moyens
nécessaires ça fera donc 1283 ETP dont
350 militaires au sein du SGDSN qui vous
sont ainsi proposés je soulligne
simplement on a toujours un poids des
restes à payer qui reste élevé bien que
nous le mettions en diminution cela
tient aux opérations immobilières
importantes que nous menons le
l'immeuble de Lancier à Rennes va être
inauguré dans les prochains jours il
accueillera à terme 200 personnes nous
avons renouveler le bail pour le pour
viginum au bâtiment d'iduponant en face
de l'hôpital georgge Pompidou et donc ça
représente des coûts et nous avons
également des travaux de réaménagement à
l'intérieur du SGDSN pour récupérer des
vieux bâtiments les retaper et les
remettre à disposition donc tout ceci
évidemment entraîne des des dépenses
assez considérable
euh si je viens maintenant sur les
sujets d'actualité vous les avez évoqué
monsieur le Président entre la guerre en
Ukraine qui nous a tout au long de
l'année et encore cette année même si
ces jour-ci une autre actualité joue
beaucoup occupé nous avons eu à faire
face aux effets des sanctions
économiques et j'y reviendrai en matière
de sécurité économique
on a vu aussi que comme le droit
international était défoncé l'attitude
de la Russie à désinhiber les états
autoritariste donc nous avons des sujets
de prolifération nucléaire
bactériologique et chimique il y a bien
sûr les conflits de frontières qui se
réveill partout et et donc des problèmes
de de droit de la guerre qui qui se
posent là aussi
partout en Afrique la Russie a étendu
son influence par la manipulation de
laformation et donc ça a été une bonne
partie du travail mais pas la seule de
figinum tout au long de l'année euh le
terrorisme islamique n'a pas disparu
malheureusement malgré les victoires au
Levant contre l'État islamique et nous
le voyons bien il est en train de
revenir aujourd'hui dans notre pays et
dans nos pays dans les pays voisins et
donc l'attaque du Hamas terroriste
contre Israël avec les massacres
épouvantables de civils va évidemment
entraîner et on le voit d'ors et déjà
des difficultés politiques et
géopolitiques extrêmement grave et
humanitaire aussi nous sommes aussi
attentifs à la montée en puissance des
puissances régionales l'Iran la Turquie
euh
qui la Chine évidemment nous préoccupe
beaucoup y compris pour le coup en
matière de cyber et en matière de des
informations et tout notre sujet de fait
est d'éviter de tomber dans le piège que
certains veulent nous tendre de the West
against the rest c'est-à-dire d'avoir
l'alliance de l'OTAN des États-Unis
desoc entau contre le reste du monde on
voit bien que c'est une tentative
politique qui est menée et qui est très
dangereuse contre laquelle donc nous
souhaitons fortement lutter pour jouer
notre rôle d'équilibre et de diplomatie
vers l'ensemble du monde par ailleurs
les enjeux climatiques commencent à
avoir de fortes conséquences en terme de
conflit de migration les sujets de
démographie que j'avais déjà évoqué
derrière devant vous les dernières
années sont en en train de monter en
puissance et on le voit effectivement
avec les conséquences des différentes
guerres mais aussi dans différents pays
et puis enfin dans les 15 mois à venir
nous allons avoir beaucoup de
calendriers électoraux qui seront
l'occasion de rebattre les cartes qui
seront également l'occasion pour des
adversaires d'essayer de nuire à la
sincérité des scrutins je pense d'abord
à nos élections européennes tout le
monde pense aussi aux élections
américaines aux élections britanniques
d'ici 1 an aux élections sénégalaises
indiennes et même russe
euh même si les résultats sont un peu
moins incertains pour ce qui concerne la
Russie euh mais nous aurons
effectivement des enjeux extrêmement
forts et les élections polonaises
viennent juste de se
dérouler face à ces évolutions nous
devons renforcer nos protections je ne
reviendrai pas sur la loi de
programmation militaire que vous avez
évoqué et que vous avez voté et pour
laquelle nous avions préparé une revue
National stratégique qui a été présenté
en novembre 2022 euh je voudrais
insister sur quelques menaces qui
permettront ensuite de passer la parole
à à mes adjoints si vous le voulez
bien ce qui nous a beaucoup occupé cette
année et avant de passer de à la
déstabilisation de l'information à la
cybersécurité c'est aussi les sujets de
sécurité économique nous avons constaté
qu'il y avait des tentatives de prise de
contrôle des entreprises après parfois
déstabilisation qui étaient extrêmement
importante de la part de différents pays
en différents endroits et alors que nous
essayons de reconstruire
notre industrie une économie qui soit
résiliente parce que c'est nécessaire
cont tenu de l'évolution de la
géopolitique d'avoir de la
relocalisation industrielle et de la
reconstruction d'un tissu économique
fort nous nous rendons compte qu'il y a
beaucoup d'activités pour essayer deer
cet aspect là ou tout du moins de
prendre contrôle de nos entreprises
l'espionnage industriel le le débauchage
des ingénieurs et des commerciaux mais
aussi l'utilisation de ce qu'on nous
appelons le faer c'est-à-dire
l'extraterritorial du droit la
judiciarisation des relations
commerciales l'édiction de normes
internationales au bénéfice d'un état
tout ceci ce sont des actions qui en
matière de sécurité économique nuisent à
la protection de notre patrimoine
scientifique et technique à la
protection de notre patrimoine
économique et nous avons très
régulièrement des réunions avec le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
mais également toutous les autres
ministères y compris ceux concernés par
la base industrielle de défense pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
protéger nos entreprises réagir en
soutenant leur capital en intervenant à
un moment ou un autre ou en bloquant les
investissements étrangers qui peuvent
être hostiles de façon à préserver une
bonne partie de de nos pépites et nous
avons tous les mois des réunions sur ce
sujet avec le le 6c au sein du Colisée
et nous en aurons encore une cet
après-midi pour regarder un certain
nombre d'entreprises en difficultés nous
faisons également du coup beaucoup de
sensibilisation vers ces entreprises
pour les amener à être prudentes que ce
soit en matière évidemment de
cybersécurité parce que certaines font
encore preuve d'une naïveté désarmante
et d'ailleurs désarmé et par ailleurs
nous faisons également très attention à
à la manipulation de l'information
contre certaines entreprises parce que
nous nous rendons compte que là aussi et
surtout dans le cadre du conflit que
nous vivons aujourd'hui mais il peut y
avoir des activités de
déstabilisation et de lutte contre leur
réputation qui peut être extrêmement
importante sur donc la déstabilisation
via les ingérences numériques étrangères
je laisserai évidemment Marc-Antoine
brillant compléter l'ensemble du sujet
et et indiquer ce qu'il en est il a eu
énormément de travail énormément de
travail
euh qui a été très bien fait
euh et je me permets de le dire mais du
coup il y a encore énormément
d'opérations sur lesquelles nous devons
nous réorganiser et retravailler ce
sujet donc nous allons essayer cette
année d'avancer sur des sujets de
stratégie pour regarder en liaison avec
le ministère des Affaires étrangères de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères avec
les autres ministères comment nous
pouvons essayer d'avoir une stratégie de
lutte contre les manipulations
d'information qui nous permettent non
seulement de réagir parce que comme
l'ANI viginium est un bouclier pas une
épée mais en même temps pour que le
bouclier soit plus efficace il faut
qu'il puisse se coordonner avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et ceux qui
peuvent être amenés à intervenir et donc
nous allons avoir tout un travail sur ce
sujet que nous allons engager il en sera
de même d'ailleurs avec Lancy qui va
aussi se lancer dans une révision de la
stratégie de lutte contre les
cyberattaques qui avaient été adopté en
2018 et donc nous souhaitons remettre au
goût du jour en 2023 pour tenir compte
là où aussi des évolutions en matière de
cybercriminalité des évolution en
matière de
cyberattaque de l'arrivée de
l'intelligence artificielle de l'arrivée
du Cantique qui vont complètement
rebattre les cartes et vont nous amener
là aussi à revoir la position encore une
fois aussi pour eux de bouclier mais là
aussi en liaison avec les autres
ministères pour jouer un un rôle d'épée
et donc je je les laisserai intervenir
pour évoquer les points vous avez parlé
monsieur le Président d'évolution de
l'état-major c'est vrai effectivement
que les deux ont changé cette année mais
en fait au sein du
SGDSN nous avons aussi un nouveau direct
une nouvelle directrice de PSE qui
s'appelle Muriel guyen qui était
auparavant au cabinet de Monsieur clin
et auparavant préfette de la Meuse puis
de la Somme et euh demain j'aurai à
choisir un nouveau directeur pour la
direction AIST ou une nouvelle
directrice puisque monsieur Toubou a
rejoint le cabinet du garde des saaus et
donc le poste é aujourd'hui vacances qui
veut dire que avec le chef du service
des affaires générales c'est en fait
tout l'état-major sauf votre serviteur
qui et son adjoint qui ont changé en en
2023 et qui auront changé en 2023 pardon
affairire international scientifique et
technologique merci monsieur le
Président merci mesdames et messieurs
donc dans le prolongement de de ce que
vient de dire le secrétaire général je
vous propose de faire un un un un
premier tour d'horizon sur la menace
cyber tel que nous l'observons avant
avant de vous brosser très rapidement de
les deux principaux défis qui nous
attendent dans l'année dans l'année qui
vient concernant la la menace cyber donc
Guillaume Poupard l'avait dit l'année
dernière ici le niveau de menace est
très élevé il a continué d'être élevé en
2022 toutefois ce que nous remarquons au
premier semestre 2023 c'est que le
nombre d'événements traités par l'ancy a
connu en comparaison avec le dernier
semestre de l'année 2022 une
augmentation encore de 23 % donc on est
toujours sur un un rythme donc en
augmentation aussi quo nous sommes
toujours confrontés à trois types de
menaces une menace étatique stratégique
si vous voulez une menace de nature
criminelle et puis une menace de type
activiste à écrire avec un H et un
K donc concernant la menace étatique ou
stratégique bon c'est le fond de
commerce vous le savez de l'agence
depuis depuis sa création donc depuis
2009 la finalité de cette menace c'est
c'est principalement de l'espionnage
mais ça peut être aussi du
sabotage et concernant le l'année 2021
et 2022 c'est vraiment ce qui occupe le
plus aujourd'hui les les équipes de
l'agence pour vous donner des chiffres
euh sur les 19 opérations de
cyberdéfense et incident majeur qui ont
été traité par l'agence en 2022 neuf
impliqués des des modes opératoires ce
que nous appelons des modes opératoire
donc des groupes qui sont affiliés en
source ouverte à la
Chine concernant ensuite la la menace
d'origine criminelle donc c'est une
menace qui est totalement indiscriminée
qui est extrêmement massive qui s'est
industrialisé qui fait ce qu'on appelle
de la de la pêche au chalu mais avec un
impact sociétal extrêmement fort
notamment comme vous l'avez rappelé avec
les attaques sur les hôpitaux sa
finalité c'est de l'extorsion de fond
tout simplement l'extorsion
en prenant en otage des données ou des
systèmes
d'information nous avons constaté une
hausse importante encore de cette menace
au premier semestre 2023 une hausse de
50 % par rapport au dernier semestre de
l'année
2022 les principales victimes ce sont
toujours les entreprises donc les TPE
les PME les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire mais aussi comme vous le
savez les collectivités
territoriale enfin concernant la la la
menace de nature revendicative donc les
activistes donc eux ce qu'ils cherchent
évidemment c'est avoir un écho dans la
presse notamment en menant des attaques
sur des sites web en les rendant
indisponibles on constate une vraie
résurgence de cette menace évidemment
avec le conflit en Ukraine et puis le
conflit plus récemment au proche- Orient
pour
autant depuis les attaques du Hamas du 7
octobre nous n'avons pas constaté
d'augmentation d'attaques de ce typeel
touchant la France même si effectivement
nous observons qu'en Israël il y a
beaucoup d'opérations d'activisme contre
contre contre Israël mené par des
groupes proalestiniens prorusses ou
pro-iraniens enfin dernier point
concernant la la menace c'est que
nousous nous observons également une
véritable porosité entre les groupes
cybercriminels et les groupes étatiques
et notamment un certain nombre de
convergenence en terme de de
technique
C ces ces menaces ces attaques se
réalisent généralement parce que il y a
un certain nombre de fragilités qui qui
perdure dans l'informatique des des
victimes c'est ces fragilités elles sont
de trois ordres des vulnérabilités
logiciell qui ne sont connus qui sont
corrigés par les éditeurs mais dont les
correctifs ne sont pas appliqués par
ceux qui soutiennent qui entretiennent
l'informatique des victimes donc ça
c'est une des causes majeures
la deuxième cause ce sont des usages
informatiques qui sont mal maîtrisés et
puis la troisième ce sont des
sous-traitants qui sont souvent mal
protégés
eux-mêmes donc j'en viiens maintenant au
au défis qui qui qui nous attendent donc
les chiffres que que je viens de vous
donner il parle de même forcé de
constater qu'on n'est pas en mesure
aujourd'hui de couvrir totalement cette
menace et c'est bien d'ailleurs
l'objectif qui nous a été fixé par le
président de la République dans la revue
nationale stratégique de donner à la
France une cyber résilience de premier
ordre donc pour tenir cet objectif nous
devons maintenant relever un défi qui
est vraiment structurel pour l'agence
qui est celui du passage à
l'échelle en effet même si on avait des
moyens qui étaient multipliés par de par
5 par 10 aujourd'hui on ne pourrait pas
répondre quand même à cette menace de
cette manière-là donc pour répondre à
une menace de cette ampleur il faut
vraiment qu'on passe d'une encore une
fois d'une logique de enfin d'une
logique de de trèsible sur les
opérateurs critiques comme on avait
jusqu'à présent mais qu'on complète
désormais avec une logique beaucoup plus
large qui nous permettra de de de
couvrir les établissements publics les
collectivités les entreprises avec
effectivement pour ces pour ces entités
là des niveaux de protection qui seront
adapt ce passage à l'échelle ça nous
demande aussi de travailler de plus en
plus en réseau et d'animer des réseaux
notamment au sein des régions vous le
savez on a grâce à France relance pu
aider à la création de centres cyber
dans 12 régions euh nous avons pu aussi
dédiés à certains secteurs d'activité je
pense à la santé je pense à l'aviation
je pense au au secteur maritime euh et
puis il y a évidemment un acteur
extrêmement important qui qui préexista
à tout cela et qui fait un travail
formidable c'est
cybermalveillance.gou.fr donc on voit
très bien qu'on a des acteurs qui qui
émerge ou qui préexistait et l'objectif
l'enjeu pour nous maintenant c'est
d'arriver à faire travailler tous ces
acteurs en réseau pour encore une fois
arriver à avoir la plus grande
couverture possible du territoire sans
oublier évidemment des prestataires
privés qui euh monte également en
compétence et se développe de plus en
plus ce passage à l'échelle pour
déployer une une cybersécurité de masse
c'est l'esprit de la directive Nice 2
euh donc qui est que nous avons voulu
lors de la présid id française de
l'Union européenne et qui doit être
transposé d'ici
2024 Nice 2 pour vous donner un chiffre
et justement qui illustre parfaitement
ce passage à l'échelle Nice 2 va nous
faire passer de aujourd'hui 500
opérateurs régulés par l'agence à
certainement environ 15000 voilà donc
effectivement on ne travaille pas avec
500 opérateurs régulés comme on
travaille avec 15000 il va falloir
vraiment
qu'on change nos
méthodes c'est une véritable ution
industrielle qu'on va vivre au sein de
l'agence pour reprendre des mots de
notre directeur général il va nous
falloir continuer à faire du du prête à
porter du pardon du surmesure donc du
surmesure pour les les opérateurs
critiques notamment ou les les
administration les plus les plus
régaliennes de l'État mais aussi
désormais il va nous falloir faire du du
prê àorter et du prê àorter de qualité
évidemment entendant par là du prê
àortter qui protège
correctement le deuxième grand défi qui
nous attend c'est et ce sera
certainement un défi pour notre pour
notre résiliance nationale c'est
évidemment les Jeux
Olympiques les Jeux Olympiques c'est une
illustration très concrète du du du
changement d'échelle que nous allons
devoir
mener comme pour les précédentes
Olympiades nous sommes absolument
convaincu que les Jeux Olympiques à
Paris vont concentrer sur notre pays un
niveau inédit d'attaqu cyber de tout
ordre les Jeux Olympiques pour vous
donner des des quelques chiffres vu de
l'an c'est 350 entités 350 entités dont
80 sont critiques critiques en ce sens
que si elles subissz une attaque
d'ampleur une attaque informatique
d'ampleur soit une épreuve sera annulée
soit une grande partie des jeux pourrait
être annulé donc c'est ça ce qu'on
appelle les entités critiques elles sont
donc au N de de
80 et beaucoup de ces acteurs n'ont
jamais été confrontés à au niveau de
menace dont j'ai parlé
précédemment donc nous devons mener avec
eux un travail massif de sécurisation
pour les les aider à monter en en
compétence sur ces questions là donc
quelques chiffres
encore le plan que nous menons
actuellement c'est une soixantaine
d'audit et autant de plans d'action qui
devront être terminés très rapidement au
au premier trimestre à la fin du premier
trimestre 2024 c'est aussi un exercice
massifié de gestion de crise puisqueon
peut pas entraîner tous ces acteurs tous
ces 350 acteurs c'est impossible donc on
distribue des kits d'entraînement et on
accompagne tous ces tous ces acteurs à
la gestion de crise c'est une
utilisation massive de nos services
automatisés d'audit pour pour les aider
à avoir des plans
d'action solide c'est aussi au-delà de
ces entités s'intéresser à
aux établissements de santé par exemple
qui seront à proximité des sites de
compétition et nous en avons recensé
aujourd'hui 210 donc c'est s'assurer que
ces 210 établissements de santé sont
effectivement bien sécurisés dans le
cadre euh des des des des plans d'action
qui sont menés par le ministère de la
Santé et de la santé c'est aussi
s'intéresser aux 10 euh et vous avez
certainement en tête l'exemple du du 10
64 qui a subi effectivement une attaque
extrêmement
importante en parallèle avec tout ça
nous mettons en place toute une
mécanique opérationnelle pour nous
assurer que nous seront capables
d'échanger très rapidement avec
l'ensemble des centres d'opération qui
qui vont qui vont qui vont gérer les les
les Jeux Olympiques enfin la principale
difficulté qu'on va avoir sur les Jeux
Olympiques c'est que ces Jeux Olympiques
effectivement ce seront deux fois 15
jours entre les Jeux Olympiques et les
je Jeux paralympiques et et en 15 jours
on ne peut pas reconstruire un système
d'information qui aurait été détruit par
un rançong
juiciel donc ça ça veut dire que
effectivement il va falloir beaucoup
miser sur une détection la plus efficace
possible des attaques pour pouvoir les
enrayer le plus tôt possible et
effectivement limiter les impacts que
ces attaques pourraient avoir c'est la
première chose et puis la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il va nous falloir mettre en
place une sorte de médecine de guerre
cyber avec des plans
de remédiation très rapide des
prestataires pour très rapidement
pouvoir intervenir et remonter le plus
vite possible les systèmes d'information
qui on été
attaqué aujourd'hui pour paraphraser une
phrase d'une série des années 80 notre
notre plan se déroule sans
accro mais nous sommes effectivement
dans la dans la partie la plus facile du
plan et très certainement ce qui nous
attend à partir du printemps sera très
différent
voilà voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire
en en
introduction monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs avec votre permission je
souhaiterais pouvoir commencer ma prise
de parole par un court et rapide propos
liminaire afin de replacer un petit peu
la mission du service viginum dans un
cadre plus global qui est celui d'un
changement radical du contexte
géopolitique qui est fondé sur un usage
décomplexé du rapport de force
aujourd'hui avec pour instrument des
actions de nature hybride dont la menace
informationnelle en est l'essence même
donc en quelques mots depuis une
vingtaine d'années nous assistons à un
véritable durcissement des relations
internationales qui les rapproche
davantage d'une compétition stratégique
désinhibée c'est-à-dire d'une
dialectique de puissance entre puissance
avec pour caractéristique majeur le
rapport de force et donc nous sommes
probablement entrés dans une air
géopolitique au sens réaliste du terme
c'est-à-dire une période d'affrontement
indirect de recherche de puissance pour
imposer sa volonté par l'influence
l'intimidation voire l'agression parfois
dans une logique opportuniste souvent de
contournement dans cette mêlé mondiale
où tous les coups sont permis les
démocraties sont à la fois contestées et
fragilisé face à des compétiteurs qu'il
soit étatique ou non usant de tous leurs
attributs la technologie les réseaux
sociaux pouvant jouer parfois un rôle de
pouvoir égalisateur
elles sont contestées dans leurs valeurs
et héritage et on le voit notamment sur
le continent africain comme ça a pu être
évoqué par le secrétaire général dans
son dans son propos fragilisé aussi dans
leur modèle notamment s'agissant des
démocraties libérales qui ont pour
fondement l'ouverture et le respect des
libertés et c'est dans cette rivalité
que naissent et s'épanouissent les
menaces hybrides véritable défi pour la
sécurité et la stabilité la menace
hybride se nourrit de ces périodes
d'incertitude entre guerre et paix comme
celle que nous vivons aujourd'hui
estompe la frontière entre l'influence
et l'ingérance en agissant par divers
moyens et modes opératoires souvent sous
le seuil de la conflictualité en ciblant
ou exploitant notre fonctionnement
démocratique notre cohésion sociale
notre économie et notre système normatif
est-ce que nous interprétons nous
aujourd'hui comme nos forces sont en
réalité des vulnérabilités du point de
vue de l'adversaire et nos
compétiteurs ce constat n'est pas
nouveau puisqu'il était parfaitement
décrit dans et vous l'avez très bien
mentionné monsieur le Président dans la
revue nationale stratégique qui a été
publié l'année dernière par le
secrétaire général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale mais ça me
permettait pour moi maintenant de vous
faire un état de la menace
informationnelle en l'ayant mis dans un
contexte plus
global alors de quoi parle-t-on on parle
d'un instrument qui est parfaitement
intégré dans les stratégies hybrides de
nos compétiteurs les manipulations de
information qui sont des manœuvres
informationnelles mises en œuvre de
manière délibérée et coordonnée visant à
l'aide de procédés techniques des loyaux
comme des automates ce qu'on appelle des
bottes des trolls ou des techniques
comme le copy pasta qui visent à
amplifier des contenus manifestement
inexacts ou trompeurs dans notre débat
public
numérique lorsque ces manœuvres
impliquent des acteurs étranger qui soi
étatique ou non et qu'ell cible les
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation tels
qu'ils sont définis
dans l'article 410-1 du code pénal ou le
l811-3 du code de la sécurité intérieure
ces manœuvres sont des ingérences
numériques étrangères et cette menace
informationnelle elle fait peser une
menace réelle et sérieux sur notre
fonctionnement démocratique et notre
cohésion car elle vise d'abord et avant
tout à produire des effets dans la vie
réelle même sil déballe est sur des
plateformes en ligne et qu'il est
virtuel nos compétiteurs visent à
produire des effets dans la vie réelle
concrètement détourner le citoyen du
vote ou orienter son vote attiser la
contestation parfois avec de la violence
physique dans la rue toucher l'économie
réelle comme l'a très bien évoqué le
secrétaire général par la promotion de
campagn de boycott qui peutvent viser
nos grandes entreprises à
l'étranger les acteurs de la menace
informationnelle appuient et s'appuient
sur des fragilités existantes comme la
défiance croissante à l'égard des
institutions la fragmentation sociale
qui peut être lié aux difficultés
économiques et les progressive de
l'esprit critique pour construire leur
manœuvre d'influence informationnelle
ils exploitent certains faits
d'actualité ou de société marquant pour
attiser des sentiments puissants comme
la frustration la victimisation ou
l'exclusion et chercher Infiné à
polariser durablement les différentes
composantes d'une même société les
différentes catégories de citoyens en
terme de tendance ces manœuvres sont de
plus en plus diffuses dans notre débat
public numérique concrètement elles ne
sont plus seulement circonscrites aux
élections elles touchent aujourd'hui
tous les sujets de société elles sont
plus élaborées dans leurs modes
opératoires et à ce titre l'intelligence
artificielle générative est un sujet de
préoccupation et plus difficile à
détecter du fait de l'usage
d'intermédiaire et de relais la
frontière entre une opinion et une
information manipulée par un acteur
étranger sera probablement de plus en
plus mince et difficile à
détecter enfin à la faveur des conflits
et des guerres elle gagne en intensité
cette menace informationnelle à la fois
par une diffusion de plus en plus
massive et rapide de contenu qui vise à
saturer notre débat mais aussi par la
combinaison de campagnes répondant à des
natures et des logiques différentes des
campagnes planifiées ou des campagnes
avec une logique
opportuniste concrètement les modes
opératoires aujourd'hui auxquels on fait
face sont multiples ils peuvent
concerner aussi bien la contrefaçon de
contenu encore une fois l'intelligence
artificielle permet d'y arriver avec
beaucoup plus de facilité en matière de
désinformation électorale de discrédit
des institutions voire d'usurpation
d'identité mais aussi d'amplification de
narratif afin de cinturer un débat
certains d'entre eux combinent l'attaque
informatique et la manipulation de
l'information je pense notamment à la ce
qu'on appelle le fameux henli donc le
piratage le vol de données et ensuite la
diffusion la divulgation la révélation
de ces données parfois en en ayant
manipulé le
contenu pour nous viginum de modes
opératoire sont particulièrement suivis
parce que probablement un petit peu plus
difficile à détecter celui de la
sous-traitance c'est-à-dire le recours à
des structure privé ou à des réseaux
informels comme des communautés pour
conduire des manœuvres le défi posé par
celui par ce mode opératoire là est
clairement celui de la détection mais
aussi de l'imputation un acteur et enfin
le deè deè mode opératoire qui nous pose
aujourd'hui des difficultés c'est ce
qu'on appelle le micro ciblage
c'està-dire le ciblage d'une audience
qui est restreinte mais qui dispose d'un
fort pouvoir de mobilisation y compris
dans la vie
réelle la manipulation de l'information
n'est pas la panage des seuls États nous
observons aussi un véritable phénomène
de marchandisation de la
désinformation avec des acteurs privés
issus du marketing digital ou de la
communication qui propose désormais des
prestations de services combinant
cyberespionnage et
influence si vous me le permettez
j'aimerais maintenant faire un un petit
tour rapide un panorama rapide des des
grands acteurs et de leurs modes
opératoir de leur stratég
qui nous vise et qui vise les intérêts
français parlons de la menace russe ou
prousse la France est l'une des cibles
privilégié des manœuvres
informationnelles menées par le
dispositif informationnel russe que ce
soit sur le territoire national et à
l'étranger et notamment sur le continent
africain pour diffuser du contenu qui
lui est favorable et discréditer ses
adversaires la Russie et ses proxy se
base aussi bien sur des acteurs
étatiques à l'instar de son réseau
diplomatique ou de ses services de
renseignement que sur des relais des
prestataires ainsi la Russie s'appuie
sur plusieurs acteurs privés spécialisés
dans le domaine de l'influence comme par
exemple entreprise structura que nous
avons dévoilé dans le cadre de la
campagne rrn en juin dernier avec le
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères ou bien évidemment la galaxie
de feu Eugenie
Prigogine la Russie a un large panel de
mode d'action des avatars sur les
réseaux sociaux pour diffuser du contenu
de propagande et les principaux
narratifs qui sont utilisé aujourd'hui
sur le territoire national son
l'instrumentalisation du contexte
politique et social et sur le continent
africain la critique de notre passé
coloniale un dernier point peut-être sur
la la menace prochinoise avant d'aborder
la mission de viginum et nos principaux
enjeux les stratégies d'influence
informationnelle chinoise dans le débat
public sont contrôlées et menées par
l'État parti et ces stratégies
s'inscrivent sur un long terme un temps
plus long elles ont pour objectif
principal de défendre les intérêts de la
France auprès d'une audience francophone
et de diffuser une image positive de la
puissance chinoise la la Chine affiche
également une volonté de discréditer les
États-Unis et l'OTAN ainsi que de
remettre en cause le modèle
occidental face à ce panorama la France
n'est pas resté en reste puisque depuis
2018 elle a renforcé progressivement son
dispositif national
défensif au travers en début d'année
2018 d'une première gouvernance
interministérielle présidée par le
secrétaire général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale qui regroupe les
principaux ministères régaliens et qui
vise à fludidifier le partage
d'information mieux comprendre les
phénomènes inauthentiques auxquel nous
faisons face et proposer des options de
réponse et à la fin de l'année 2018 on a
renforcé l'arsenal législatif avec deux
lois les deux lois du 22 décembre 2018
qui renforce à la fois les pouvoirs de
l'arcom et aussi du juge des référés à
l'issue des attentats de Conflant
saint-honorine en 2020 et de Nice en
2021 il étit décidé de doter le sdsn
d'un opérateur dédié et de modifier dans
le code de défense les missions du egdsn
avec à la fois une mission
d'identification des opérations
d'ingérance numérique étrangère mais
aussi une mission d'animation de
coordination des travaux de protection
et pour se faire le SGDSN dispose d'un
opérateur dédié
viginum en quelques mots pour pour
conclure quels sont les principaux
enjeux pour nous dans les prochains mois
en plus de ce qui a été évoqué par le
général nelen s'agissant de lany c'estàd
les élections européennes et les JO pour
viginum sur la période
2023-2025 nous avons pour ambition
d'assoir notre et de consolider notre
rôle de référent national en matière de
protection contre les campagnes
numériques de manipulation de
l'information à la fois en élevant notre
niveau d'expertise technique mais aussi
en nous ouvrant de nouvelles
perspectives en matière de partenariat
stratégique et donc nous avons initié
cette année un un premier forum
académique donc d'ouverture vers le
monde académique et nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui poursuivre cette démarche
d'ouverture non pas pour seulement mieux
travailler des centres de recherche mais
parce que nous sommes résolument
convaincu que ça contribuera à une
meilleure information du grand public
sur cette menace
informationnelle nous souhaitons aussi
également mieux coordonner l'ensemble
des acteurs qui sont Isus des
différentes spères d'action que ce soit
les sphères d'action publique privé et
de la société civile pour infin mieux
renforcer la résilience de la société
face à ces phénomènes et enfin nous nous
attellerons à accroître la coopération
avec nos partenaires étrangers
internationaux afin d'avoir un meilleur
partage d'information et peut-être
demain de mieux anticiper la menace
voilà pour mon
propos merci juste avant voulez encore
interir juste un mot monsieur le
Président si vous permet pour simplement
dire pour dire que tout ceci nous amène
à travailler sur les sujets de
résilience c'est-à-dire de résistance de
notre pays en anticipant sur ce type de
crise que ce soit des crises cyber que
ce soit des crises géopolitiques que
nous sommes en train donc de mettre en
place une stratégie nationale qui non
seulement concerne l'état mais concerne
aussi les collectivités locales nous
sommes en train de travailler avec les
mairies les départements les régions
pour regarder comment nous pouvons
travailler ensemble comme nous avons
réussi à le faire lors de la crise du
covid enfin en deuxième partie au début
on a un peu patouillé mais après en
travaillant avec les collectivités
locales on on a réussi à faire face à ce
type de crise et donc c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire aujourd'hui à nouveau
en anticipation et aussi en associant
ensuite les citoyens pour que ceux-ci
puisse jouer pleinement leur rôle auprès
des maires auprès des départements
auprès de l'État pour non seulement être
des consommateurs de sécurité mais aussi
des acteurs de sécurité
merci Monsieur le Directeur je voudrais
rappeler évidemment à à l'ensemble des
collègues et ceux qui nous écoutent le
rôle majeur que jouent vos agences dans
ce que le chef d'état-major théorisit
mais malheureusement qu' n'est plus une
théorie de la guerre de haute intensité
qui est celle qui consiste évidemment
d'abord à gagner la guerre avant la
guerre et gagner la guerre avant la
guerre c'est évidemment être prêt ou en
tout cas disponible et actif sur la les
questions de lutte cyber
informationnelle numérique c'est en quoi
vous vous êtes évidemment des acteurs
majeurs et c'est très important de
pouvoir vous écouter aujourd'hui on est
évidemment sur des questions budgétaires
mais je pense qu'on aura cont tenu des
enjeux majeur que nous avons à relever
dans les nous aurons à relever
rapidement de vous nous aurons
l'occasion de vous entendre à nouveau
sur ces questions mais je laisse la
parole d'abord à nos deux rapporteurs
d'abord Olivier cadiic et puis michaelll
Valy et ensuite les c'est comment les
commissaires qui souhaiteront poser des
questions
merci merci monsieur le Président euh
tout d'abord avant de commencer mon
propos je voudrais vous remercier
Monsieur le Secrétaire général et enfin
vous trois pour la clarté de votre
propos l'audition est captée mais vous
n'avez pas hésité à appeler un chat un
chat et caractériser effectivement les
États qui ne nous veulent pas que du
bien et donc c'est je pense quelque
chose d'intéressant que vous puissiez le
faire de de la sorte une bonne
information deuxème propos c'est vous
dire que lors des les auditions
précédentes puisque nous ça fait
maintenant plusieurs années que nous
nous voyons je veux vous dire que nous
avons l'impression d'être écouté et
entendu et donc à ce titre làà je
voudrais vous remercier doublement
euh pour la première partie donc entre
les quelques 831 intrusions répertorié
en 2022 par l'any dans sa publication
annuelle du panorama de la cybermenace
dont vous avez fait état et les 170000
demandes d'assistance reçu par le p
Assima cyber
malveillance une clarification doit être
apportée pour bien comprendre la
stratégie du SGDSN pour atteindre
l'objectif de la revue nationale
stratégique d'une résilience cyber de
premier rang aussi bien pour les
opérateurs d'intérêt vital que les PME
les collectivités et les particuliers al
on a bien compris que pour le haut du
panier l'application de la directive
européenne dite Nice 2 devrait conduire
l'ANI à décupler son champ de compétence
vous l'avez
exprimé donc on parle bien d'environ 700
OIV actuellement suivis par l'agence et
d'après les estimations donc vous nous
dites là maintenant 15000 entreprises
pour être concerné lorsque la directive
sera transposée d'ici à fin 20 20000 fin
2024 pour nous ce qui est intéressant
c'est de savoir puisque là vous avez dit
que c'était un défi mais comment vous
allez euh vous confrontez à ce défi
comment vous allez pouvoir réaliser ce
passage de la cybersécurité à l'échelle
industrielle prévu par
l'ANC avez-vous un calendrier de
transposition de cette directive une
liste des obligations nouvelles qui
pèseront sur les entreprises et une
estimation du coût qu'elles devront
supporter et quel service l'an leur
apportera-t-elle
juste comme ça la semaine dernière
j'étais à Washington il y avait l'ancien
président de Paypal qui était là il nous
a dit qu'il avait ils avaient 3 à 4
millions d'attaques par jour donc pour
voir un peu le niveau auquel les
entreprises sont confronté à l'autre
extrémité du spectre nous avons je
dirais le le grand
public nous avons les PME les TPE les
PME et à peine une quinzaine de
personnes et un budget de seulement 2
millions d'euros sont les moyens du GP
cyber malveillance et tout ça nous
semble dérisoire pour couvrir les
besoins du grand public des
collectivités des PME et de ses
associations quels objectifs fixez-vous
à ce groupement notamment s'il est
appelé à gérer le futur guichet unique
17 cyber que nous appelons de nos vœux
ici au Sénat depuis maintenant 5 ans et
qui que nous attendons toujours et je
rappelle que le Président de la
République l'a aussi demandé il y a
maintenant 2 ans entre ces deux spectres
vous avez la création vous avez fait
l'an la création des centres régionaux
de réponse
cyber ils ont été encouragés financé
dans le cadre du plan de relance leur
montée en puissance est
lente leurs services sont très inégaux
d'après les remontées de terrain leur
financement par l'État n'est pas péren
et on comprend mieux pourquoi une région
au ronalpe n'est pas entrée dans le
dispositif les autres régions notamment
la nouvelle Aquitaine redoute de devoir
reprendre à leur charge des missions de
sécurité qu'elles estiment
régaliennes quelle réponse apportez-vous
sur le financement et la coordination de
ces centres r régionaux disposez-vous
d'un bilan de leurs
actions enfin je vis partager avec vous
une réflexion puisque j'étais il y a 3
semaines à Taïwan et j'ai rencontré
votre interlocuteur le SGDSN et et
taiïwan est certainement aujourd'hui la
première destination des attaques et où
l'influence et se combine avec
l'ingérance ces attaques venant
effectivement de la Chine et il se il
s'avère que c'est un peu le laboratoire
des attaques cyberes pour le monde et
que lorsqu'on a vu ces attaques testées
sur taiïwan on les retrouve après
partout dans le monde Taïwan organise
des exercices internationaux euh cyber
alors je ne vais pas vous demander ici
si vous allez y participer mais euh je
voudrais savoir si euh vous participez à
des exercices internationaux au niveau
de la cyber je vous remercie Mel
oui messieur bonjour monsieur le
Président je vous prie bien vouloir
excuser mon en retard nous avions une
réunion du bureau à laquelle on ne
pouvait pas se se soustraire j'ai manqué
le début de votre intervention donc s'il
y a une redondance je vous prie de bien
vouloir m'en excuser par avance vous
avez évoqué au début de votre
intervention semble-t-il la question des
Jeux Olympiques est-ce que vous pourriez
parce que Mo je vais pas à Taiwan je
vais pas à Washington mais je viens à
Paris de temps en
temps
et je n'ai que mon département pour
circonscription néanmoins comme il
m'arrive de venir à Paris toutes les
semaines et puis qu'il y a un petit
sujet sur les je olympiques je voudrais
que vous puissiez nous préciser plus
avant quel est votre positionnement et
votre rôle dans la cyber les aspects de
cybersécurité que nous allons devoir
assurer dans le cadre des Jeux
Olympiques parce que on a évidemment et
du fait de l'actualité difficile et
tendu du moment des risques qu'on voit
se
réhausser c'est une question qui
travaille l'opinion jusqu'à la question
des punaises de lit enfin là tout le
monde va être fixé sur les Jeux
Olympiques sur la question de la
cybersécurité
quel est votre rôle je dirais en ligne
directe vis-à-vis du du comité
d'organisation vis-à-vis de la
collectivité parisienne quels sont les
prestataires les plus importants vers
qui vous vous êtes tourné et pour
assurer quel type de quel type de
préparation face à quel risque qu'est-
si tentez que vous puissiez identifier
dans une audition publique les risques
qui vous semblent les plus les plus
importants pour pas donner des idées non
plus à des personnes malveillantes mais
comment est-ce que vous organisez
là-dessus parce que je pense que et
c'est l'objet de ma je fais le lien avec
la question suivante dans la mesure où
il nous a été expliqué en audition que
finalement sur les scrutins les plus
importants que nous avons eu récemment
la présidentielle il n'y a pas eu de
comment dire d'attaque ou de volonté de
manipulation aussi manifeste que dans
d'autres démocraties ces dernières
années sur le plan de la manipulation de
l'information de la sinc sincérité du
scrutin là je me tourne plus vers
viginum le
référendum
Nouvelle-Calédonie nous avions ont posé
la question on nous a dit non finalement
les ingérences qu'on aurait pu attendre
par des acteurs que vous avez cité et en
l'occurrence pas les Russes n'ont pas eu
lieu euh donc je je pense que les Jeux
Olympiques vont être un moment important
pour évaluer notre dispositif et
j'aurais voulu pouvoir vous entendre sur
l'aspect vraiment pratique pour
prolonger la question de mon mon
collègue Cadic sur la façon de
s'organiser entre les différentes
strates
euh l'état la question des des régions
cyber
malveillance le fait de faire attention
à ce que les uns ne pensent pas que les
autres font le travail et en fait
finalement plus personne ne le fait que
avec une petite dose de mauvaise foi
qu'on peut avoir les uns les autres on
espère que l'autre va financer quand
soi-ême on n' pas à le faire est-ce que
finalement votre enjeu principal et
comment est-ce que vous vous y
confrontez n'est pas de développer la
question de l'hygiène numérique et de la
culture parce que mettre les moyens et
mettre les parfeux sur le moment c'est
une chose mais tant que nous n'aurons
pas une conscience globale
c'est-à-dire des différents acteurs
étatique jusqu'au citoyens lambda
finalement on va on va vider la mer avec
une petite cuillère comment est-ce que
làdessus vous envisagez de monter en
puissance et là on fait le lien sur les
aspects sur les aspects budgétaires et
puis une dernière question dans la
mesure où nous doutons pas du fait que
vous vous lisez de manière attentive et
peut-être même que vous punaisez
audessus de votre bureau les rapports
annuels de la commission sur le sujet
nous avions pointé l'an dernier un point
de vigilance qui est au regard des
attaques répétées qu'il y a eu sur les
structures hospitalières la question des
structures hospitalières outreem parce
que quand ce n'est pas outreem on peut
essayer de basculer d'un hôpital l'autre
les plus grandes urgen il y a pas besoin
d'attaque informatique hein l'hôpital
est dans un état tel qu'on a aussi tout
simplement par par pénurie de médecin
certains weekends de des patients qu' on
transfert d'un hôpital à l'autre en
province ce qui paraît complètement
étonnant et pourtant c'est le cas mais
sur la question de l'hôpital en outreem
avez-vous avez-vous pris en compte nos
remarques est-ce que vous estimer que
c'était exagéré ou pas exagéré et
qu'est-ce que vous en avez
fait pour viginum parce queil y a il y
avait une question quand même aussi pour
viginum sur donc depuis la CR de viginum
en 2021 il nous a semblé quand même que
ce service s'est montré un peu discret
dans sa montée en puissance et dans la
communication de ses résultats donc à
part une communication notable faite par
le ministère des Affaires étrangères sur
une affaire justement vous l'avez évoqué
qui venait de de Russie en Afrique
quelles actions pouvez-vous nous décrire
pour justifier l'activité le
développement du service
merci je vous laisse vous répartir les
je vais ouvrir et puis comme tout à
l'heure je je passerai les éléments
peut-être d'abord sur sur la dernière
question que le le sénateur Kadic et le
rapporteur Kadic a posé vinum
effectivement a été discret alors il l'
a été en plus pendant la période de la
campagne présidentielle et et c'était
très volontaire puisque nous étions
j'allais dire non pas au service de
l'État mais d'abord au service du juge
de l'élection donc nous rendions compte
à ce moment-là au Conseil
constitutionnel à la Commission
nationale de contrôle de la campagne
électorale en vu de l'élection
présidentielle et à l'arcom de tout ce
que nous voyons de tout ce que nous
détections et nous nous euh nous ne
bougions plus une oreille si je puis
dire en attendant que le juge de
l'élection décide ou pas d'en parler ou
d'intervenir et nous n'avons révélé au
grand public si je puis dire l'opération
befs qu'après les élections avec
l'accord du Conseil constitutionnel pour
pouvoir permettre aux journaux de savoir
ce qui s'était passé à cette époque-là
mais tout au long des investigations des
relevés que nous avons eu sur cette
affaire et sur d'autres nous avons
chaque fois je dire presque chaque soir
fait passer par motard à au Conseil
constitutionnel et au Palais-Royal enfin
au deux l'ensemble des éléments que nous
pouvions avoir sur ce sujet donc on
pourra vous donner un peu plus
d'éléments sur ce sur ce point ce que
nous souhaitons en tout cas sur
virginium maintenant c'est développer le
travail académique avec les f tank avec
les univers cé pour pouvoir exploiter
l'ensemble des informations que nous
avons et travailler aussi sur un aspect
éducatif vers le grand public et je
reviens sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure à la fois sur les aspects cyber
mais aussi sur les aspects manipulation
de l'information il est absolument
indispensable que nos concitoyens
sachent ce qu'ils voi sur Internet ou
autre pour nous la question de fond ça
n'est pas de dire ça c'est vrai ça c'est
faux je suis pas légitime pour le faire
et et en plus si je le disais les gens
comprendrai le contraire vous voudraz
croire le contraire donc franchement ça
c'est simplement pour voir expliquer aux
gens que quand ils pensent parler avec
leurs voisins de Valencienne de
Carpentra de La Rochelle en fait non ils
sont en train de discuter avec un agent
des services de renseignement qui est
installé à Ankara
ou ailleurs euh à
Pékin en Russie et lorsqu'ils pensent
qu'ils sont euh des dizaines ou des
centaines de milliers à dire oui je suis
d'accord avec telle opinion en fait ces
centaines de milliers de personnes sont
nées d'un clic qui a été expédié entre
1h et 1h un qu5 et qui a déclenché
quelques centaines de milliers
d'ordinateurs à travers la planète parce
qu'ils ont été contrôlés ensuite si les
gens veulent croire les informations
qu'ils ont vu c'est leur choix et ça
n'est pas notre rôle de dire ça c'est
vrai ça c'est faux mais nous essayons
simplement de démonter le mécanisme
d'authenticité de la de l' formation qui
est arrivée et donc c'est là-dessus que
nous essayons également de travailler
avec l'Éducation nationale on va essayer
aussi de monter quelque chose sur
l'informatique et justement avec le
Centre national d'enseignement à
distance pour essayer de faire passer
des tutoriels tels qu'ils l'ont fait en
matière de en matière d'environnement
nous allons essayer effectivement de de
pousser fortement les les feux sur ce
sujet euh je vais ensuite laisser mes
mes collègues compléter
sur les sujets des deux directives donc
Nice 2 mais également résilience des
entités critiques qui vont vous être
présenté dans le courant de l'année 2024
nous avons tout un travail ministériel
interministériel qui est d'ors et déjà
engagé pour regarder ce que nous allons
faire ce que nous allons mettre en œuvre
j'ajoute que non seulement il y aura des
entreprises mais il y aura aussi des
collectivités locales qui seront
concernées donc nous sommes en train de
regarder avec les grandes associations
de collectivités locales le niveau que
nous pouvons demander pour protéger les
uns et les autres on va évidemment pas
demander à une commune de 350 ou de 1000
habitants de se protéger de la même
manière que Lyon Marseille ou une grande
région donc il va falloir adapter ce ce
dispositif mais on en discutait aussi
avec le président des intercommunalités
avec le président Martin on sait aussi
que lorsqu'il y a une intercommunalité
si celle-ci doit être attaquée et elle
le sont de plus en plus ça va passer
généralement par les points les plus
faibles les petites collectivités donc
qui va falloir pouvoir regarder comment
on peut avancer sur ce sujet et donc
nous regarderons aussi comment en
utilisant les dispositifs de soutien au
collectivités local on peut aider les
collectivités locales à avancer sur ce
sujet
euh ça m'amène aussi à intervenir sur le
sujet des aides il y a eu France relance
nous avons différents dispositifs et on
va y revenir sur ce domaine mais
j'allais dire c'est comme quand on est
chez soi les serrures à mettre sur les
portes les barreaux à mettre aux
fenêtres les coffres à installer pour
que les secrets ne disparaissent pas
c'est à chacun d'entre nous de les
prévoir et les engager parce que
maintenant ça fait partie
malheureusement de la vie que nous
pouvons avoir pomper les données d'une
collectivité locale c'est non seulement
euh la mettre en danger essayer
d'obtenir une rançon c'est aussi vendre
ses données vers des le Dark web qui va
permettre à des truyants d'attaquer les
possesseurs de ces données ou de
réutiliser ses données pour casser des
codes qui vont permettre de pouvoir
entrer encore ailleurs donc on est
vraiment dans une situation où chacun
doit pouvoir jouer son rôle nous le
faisons et nous avons prévu des moyens
pour le faire mais je pense que de la
même manière que les collectivités
locales les entreprise les particuliers
font en sorte que leur maison ne soit
pas cambriolée ben il faut qu'ils
fassent en sorte que leur ordinateur ne
soit pas si je puis dire cambriolé je
vous laisse si vous voulez bien répondre
sur ce oui merci Monsieur le Secrétaire
général donc tout d'abord concernant
Nice 2 euh effectivement c'est un texte
crucial qui encore une fois que nous
avons voulu hein lors de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne donc
nous avons beaucoup travaillé dessus
nous en sommes très contents l'objectif
nous est fixé de l'avoir transposé euh
le 17 octobre 2024 donc on n pas le
choix là-dessus donc effectivement en
terme de de de calendrier c'est un
calendrier assez tendu auquel nous
sommes confrontés pour comme vous l'a
dit le secrétaire général vous proposer
un texte au au au printemps 2024 d'ici
là qu'est-ce que nous allons faire Nice
2 effectivement ça révolutionne beaucoup
de choses ça va nous obliger à parler
notamment à des PME à des ETI et à des
collectivités d'une taille que nous
avions pas l'habitude de traiter et
effectivement on ne parle pas à un
patron de PME ou à un élu d'une
collectivité d'une petite mairie une
petite commune comme on parle
effectivement un opérateur d'importance
vitale ou à une grande administration il
n'a pas les mêmes moyens donc
effectivement il faut trouver des
solutions adaptées donc ce que nous
allons faire là dans le courant du mois
de de novembre décembre c'est une série
de consultations euh pour partager
plusieurs choses partager d'abord
effectivement la manière dont on va
interagir avec tous ces nouveaux acteurs
encore une fois jusqu'à présent on avait
une relation assez intime avec les
opérateurs critiques on se connaissait
on échangeait régulièrement demain avec
15 15000 entités régulées on ne pourra
pas avoir ce niveau de connaissance et
de de relation pour autant il va bien
falloir que ces entités se connaissent
sachent qu'elles sont désormais régulées
qu'elles ont des choses à faire et donc
il faut qu'on modifie notre façon de de
de discuter avec ces entités donc là il
va y avoir une consultation spécifique
là-dessus pour savoir effectivement
comment on interagit maintenant avec ces
nouvelles entités la deuxième
consultation qu'on va mener c'est sur le
périmètre comme l'a dit le secrétaire
général jusqu'où on va
en terme de taille d'entreprise en terme
de taille de collectivité est-ce qu'on
prend toutes les collectivités
territorial de France ou est-ce qu'on
s'arrête à un certain niveau est-ce
qu'on prend toutes les entreprises de
France et de Navar ou est-ce qu'on
s'arrête à un certain niveau voilà ça
c'est aussi le un sujet très important
qu'on qu'on va débattre discuter avec
les les les grandes
associations et puis la dernière
consultation que nous allons mener c'est
sur les règles puisque effectivement on
ne peut pas poser le même niveau des
exigence encore une fois à un OIV et à
une PME ou une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire il faut arriver à trouver
des exigences qui soient efficace mais
atteignable avec les moyens dont chacun
dispose voilà donc l'idée n'est pas pour
nous de de de faire tout ça en chambre
encore une fois mais bien d'avoir une
série de consultations trois
consultations pour arriver à avoir un
débat constructif et à nous faire
progresser parce que très honnêtement
c'est un sujet très nouveau pour nous et
on est loin de prétendre d'avoir la la
la vérité sur ces questions là
quoi juste un mot vous le savez bien
parce queà chaque fois qu'on a des
directives on a le même sujet les
directives européennes elles sont prises
en compte pour faire face à des linders
à des grandes régions et à quelques
milliers de communes ou départements
grand maximum nous nous avons 36000
communes et donc il faut évidemment que
nous adaptions ces règles à ce que nous
sommes à notre manière de fonctionner
sans handicaper évidemment nos
collectivités sans leur mettre un poids
excessif sur le dos j'allais dire que
même si elles sont attaquables d'une
certaine manière leur petite taille les
protège c'est un peu comme dans la
jungle Strubel dit souvent le dans la
jungle quand un Lyon vous court après la
question c'est pas de courir plus vite
que le liyon c'est de courir plus vite
que le voisin et
donc et et donc sous cet angle là si
attaquer des petites collectivités
représentent un travail important mais
ne rapporte pas grand-chose parce
qu'elles sont petites peut-être que nos
compétiteurs iront regarder ailleurs les
plus grosses collectivités qui peuvent
rapporter davantage donc il faut qu'on
ait une protection qui soit minimale qui
permette de prendre en compte un certain
nombre de choses et là et et qu' ne soit
évidemment pas trop trop coûteuse pour
les uns et les autres parce qu'il faut
pas non plus entraver le mode de
fonctionnement de nos collectivités et
c'est tout le travail que nous allons
avoir à faire avec les associations et
évidemment avec
vous pour compléter peut-être illustrer
de ça encore de manière plus concrète on
développe actuellement un service en
ligne qu'on appelle mon service sécurisé
mon service sécurisé c'est un service en
ligne de l'agence qui va permettre
demain à une mairie qui n'a aucune
expertise en cybersécurité à travers un
parcours qu'on va accompagner en à peu
près 1 heure voire 2 he de s'assurer que
bah le service en ligne d'ê sociale
qu'elle souhaite mettre à la disposition
de ses administrés et ben ce service en
ligne effectivement il ne va pas fuiter
des informations personnelles sur les
administrés donc ça c'est un outil une
approche un peu nouvelle pour nous pour
aider encore une fois bah les
administrations les les petites
administrations les petits
établissements publics les les les les
petites collectivités à se poser
rapidement les bonnes questions et à y
trouver un certain nombre de réponses
élémentaires qui rejoignent ce que vous
disiez sur l'hygiène de
cybersécurité concernant le le
le dispositif cyber malveillance les
6urs régionaux les 6S
sectoriels aujourd'hui notre objectif
c'est que chaque victime d'attaque cyber
est au moins un interlocuteur un
intervenant à sa
disposition c'est ça notre objectif et
on en est encore très loin euh
aujourd'hui on n pas assez
d'acteurs locaux régionaux qui
permettent effectivement d'apporter des
réponses à des TPE des particuliers des
associations des collectivités
minintérieur voilà donc on on est très
loin d'arriver à à faire un jardin à la
française si vous voulez comme dit mon
directeur général aujourd'hui notre
notre enjeu c'est d'arriver à faire
pousser des arbres dans notre jardin et
puis effectivement quand on aura
suffisamment d'arbres peut-être qu'on se
s'assurera qu'ils sont bien taillé que
les lignes sont droites et que chacun
effectivement a un périmètre bien bien
défini mais aujourd'hui notre notre
sujet c'est d'arriver à faire émerger un
très grand nombre d'acteurs le plus
grand nombre d'acteurs poss possible et
effectivement vous avez dit que les
sorts régionaux ne sont pas encore
complètement opérationnels nous
partageons complètement complètement
cela mais nous sommes dans une phase
d'accompagnement de ces sissorts
régionaux pour nous assurer qu'ils
deviennent très rapidement le plus
opérationnel possible et qu'il soi
effectivement le plus efficace possible
sur leur région pour nous permettre
effectivement d'avoir une réponse aux
victimes de cette région donc nous
sommes vraiment sur une approche de
monter en puissance avec peut-être que
dans 10 ans on se posera des questions
de de périmètres
extrêmement extrêmement précis à à
traiter mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
encore le le sujet quoi et et j'ajoute
que le ministerère de l'intérieur avec
la gendarmerie la police a mis en place
un service à compétence nationale et
toute une organisation qui est destinée
à venir aider les collectivités locales
et les particuliers et notamment à
lutter contre la
cyberdlinquence mais là je je vous
renvoie à à mon ancien patron mais on
avance sur ce sujet un point sur les
Jeux Olympiques Lancy a été désigné
comme pilote de la lutte contre la cyber
contre les cyberattaques lors des Jeux
olympiques donc il y a un dispositif qui
est mis en place et qui fonctionnera h
24 pendant les Jeux Olympiques qui d'ors
et déjà fonctionne avec un système
d'astreinte de façon à pouvoir répondre
aux questions des uns et des autres euh
l'ANI s'occupe des 80 opérateurs très
sensibles qu'on a évoqué qui peuvent
être non seulement les stades et
certains nécessiter effectivement qu'on
aille regarder ce qui s'y passer et il y
a des corrections à faire ça peut être
évidemment les systèmes de transport
ensuite nous avons un deuxième cercle
sur
lequel l'ussi surveille des entreprises
privées qui sont au service de ces
opérateurs et qui vont venir aider
tester accompagner voir ce qu'il en est
et puis il y a un 3è cercle encore un
peu plus éloigné où là on fera un peu de
temps en temps de sondages pour regarder
si tout le monde est bien et si tout le
monde a bien pris en compte les mesures
sachant que lors des processus
contractuels et de travail avec ses
entreprise il leur ait demandé
évidemment d'être attentif et vigilant
sur leur sujet de cybersécurité ce sera
d'ailleurs une question qui à un moment
ou un autre se posera euh y compris en
matière de marché public et de contrôle
ce sera de voir si dans le cahier des
charges on ne demande pas au aux
entrepreneurs d'avoir des mesures de
sécurité qui permettent tout simplement
de ne pas planter un service public à
côté on sait que dans les hôpitaux
parfois c'est par des entreprises
extérieures et des fournisseurs que la
porte arrière s'est ouverte et donc que
l'hôpital a été attaqué malgré toutes
les précautions qu'il avait pu faire
donc il faudra sans doute qu'on
réfléchisse sur ce sujet et ça sera sans
doute aussi un des aspects sur lesquel
vous aurez à
voter
in il y avait des des questions
peut-être oui oui monsieur le Président
sur votre question monsieur le
rapporteur s'agissant des actions que je
pourrais vous décrire et donc qui
justifient l'activité opérationnelle de
viginum le je pourrais vous donner
quelques chiffres qui sont issues du
premier rapport public de viginum qui a
été publié en fin d'année dernière au
cours de l'année 2022 viginum a
travaillé sur à peu près un peu moins de
140 phénomènes inauthentiques donc ce
que nous appelons nous un phénomène
inauthentique dans le débat public
numérique c'est un comportement atypique
ou aberrant c'est un contenu qui est
manifestement trompeur ou c'est des
comptes et des profils puisque vginium
travaille sur des comptes et des profils
pas sur des individus donc comptes et
des profils qui présentent beaucoup de
caractéristiques d'inauthenticité et
donc au travers de ces 140 phénomènes
inauthentiques que nous avons
détectés le service a pu caractériser à
peu près une douzaine d'ingérance
numérique étrangère donc c'est-à-dire
d'opération qui à la fois impliquaient
des acteurs étrangers qui soitent
étatiqu couon qui visait à amplifier de
manière artificielle automatisée des
contenus manifestement inexacts ou
trompeurs avec la finalité d'atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
le secrétaire général évoquit avec vous
le phénomène baisse pendant l'élection
donc ce phénomène nous avons pu le
rendre public via un documentaire
télévisé de complément d'enquête et puis
bah donc beaucoup plus récemment cet été
en 2023 vous avez vu le fameux la
fameuse campagne qu'on a baptisé rrn et
qui visait dans le cadre de la guerre
Russie-Ukraine
à usurper l'identité de vrais médias et
éventuellement de sites officiels je
pense notamment celui du korais pour y
diffuser du contenu totalement faux et
donc quand vous êtes un internaute et
que vous surfez sur les réseaux sociaux
bah vous allez tomber à un moment sur un
site qui ressemble comme j'allais dire à
s méprendre à un site officiel ou un
site de média officiel sauf
qu'évidemment le contenu n'est pas
exactement le même donc ça c'est des
données on va dire à peu près précises
qu'on qu'on a pu publier et qui justifi
l'activité du service
et sur la la discrétion de viginum juste
pour compléter les les propos du
secrétaire
général viginum il vient de de de fêter
son 2e anniversaire c'est très récent et
l'impératif que nous avions et la
directive qui m'avait été donnée c'était
de pouvoir créer une capacité
opérationnelle crédible dans un premier
temps et je pense qu'on avait aussi un
aveu d'humilité sur les deux premières
années du service pu que c'était un
service une capacité nouvelle à faire
cet effort de crédibilisation de mettre
cette capacité opérationnelle à
l'épreuve d'élection mais à preuve
d'autres événements ce qui justifie
aussi la relative discrétion que nous
avons eu jusqu'à
présent merci beaucoup je je avant de
laisser la parole aux autres
commissaires je voudrais juste revenir
rapidement sur la question qui a été
posée par Michel Valy concernant les
Jeux Olympiques et les moyens que vous
avez ou les moyens supplémentaires qui
sont mis à votre disposition alors si
vous pouvezf si vous l'avez
volontairement effacé éludé et que vous
souhaitez qu'on y réponde à ça me pose
pas de problème mais juste qu'on se le
dise et puis queon puisse avoir une
réponse
oui effectivement sur les Jeux
Olympiques on a eu dans le cadre de la
loi Jo environ 10 millions d'euros qui
nous ont été alloués pour faire
effectivement permettre la sécurisation
des entités critiques qui ont été évoqué
précédemment donc concrètement on a on
est on a mené un certain nombre d'
d'audits ou fait mener des audits par
des prestataires privés ces audits nous
ont permettre d'avoir des plans d'action
maintenant et ces plans d'action voilà
ils sont en cours de réalisation et
notre objectif c'est qu'à la fin du
idéalement à la fin du premier trimestre
2024 ces plans d'action a été réalisé
parce que après on sait qu'on va être
très près des de l'échéance et que ce
sera très difficile de continuer à
sécuriser merci beaucoup donc je passe
maintenant aux questions une minute une
question selon la règle donc je commence
avec Joël garot Joë guerot pardon j'ai
failli j'ai fa j'ai ma langue a failli
fourcher merci président euh on a on
assiste à un tsunami de l'information et
à travers cette information non
importante il est toujours difficile
d'apprécier ce qui fait partie des fake
news pour autant souvent les plus
efficaces sont les petits messages très
courts qui sont retenus par par notre
cerveau et on a bien mesuré à travers
les constats que vous nous avez présenté
la difficulté de lutter contre ce ce
phénomène euh vous avez évoqué les lois
de 2018 en particulier est-ce que vous
voyez aujourd'hui à travers ces constats
que vous nous avez donné des
modifications réglementaires que nous
pourrions apporter pour pour renforcer
encore davantage notre sécurisation sur
ce sur le plan législatif d'une part moi
ce que ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est
tout ce qui peut-être les informations
qui sont très agressives qui conduisent
à la violence et qui font que finalement
quand on est dans la violence virtuelle
au moment on passe dans la violence
réelle il y a une il y a une comment
désensibilisation de nos populations à
des actes de violence eu égard au fait
que les réseaux emportent énormément
voilà donc quel réglement qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour faire évoluer
notre réglementation et renforcer nos
chances de lutter contre ces
phénomènes merci Joë je vais faire des
séries de trois questions si vous le
Souha voulez bien donc François bonau
s'il vous plaît
oui merci à chacun pour pour votre
exposé les les réponses que vous avez pu
apporter plus spécifiquement je je veis
vous parler l'intelligence artificielle
et etia générative même si elle est on
pourrait on pourrait l'appeler autrement
automatisation numérique puisquil s'agit
pas proprement parler d'intelligence
mais t toujours est-il que aujourd'hui
nous sommes qu'à ces débuts et que c'est
un défi redoutable qui est qui est qui
est
fait à nos états et savoir comment vous
souhaitez y répondre sachant
qu'effectivement nous sommes qu'au début
de cette histoire qui va bouleverser
beaucoup de
choses François ludovicque
et je faisais le lien entre deux deux de
mes collègues euh merci président merci
Monsieur le Secrétaire général mon
Général Monsieur le Directeur de de
merci merci cher Marc Antoine euh
j'aurais voulu vous déjà je vrais vous
remercier par rapport à au panorama
numérique que vous avez pu dresser sur
aussi précis sur un sujet qui n l''est
pas forcément dans un temps record je
vais essayer de de faire aussi bien que
vous si c'est possible euh je voulais
également vous j'aurais bien aimé vous
vous poser des tonnes de questions mais
je crois que pour respect pour mes
collègues je vais je vais m'entenir à
l'aspect quantitatif
de de la donnée
numérique aujourd'hui comme vous le
savez la quantité est bien souvent
l'ennemi de la qualité et le numérique
n'y échappe pas les chiffres parlent
deux même sans vous abreuver de chiffre
on était à 60 zabyte il y a 3 ans zabyte
pour ceux qui ne ne l'ont plus en tête
c'est 10^iss 21 donc à l'èair où on
parle encore de giga 10^ 9 dans
certaines entreprises vous imaginez le
saut de quantité qu'on a pu faire et
quand bien même on change d'unité on
voit que même la progression on passe de
60 à 180 l'année prochaine estimé donc
on est sur une véritable explosion des
données
euh lorsque je vous ai dit ça je vous
dirais également qu'en France on assiste
aussi à une sorte de syndrome de Diogène
numérique c'est-à-dire qu'on on vous
reprochera jamais de produire ou de
stocker de la donnée en revanche bien
évidemment et vous l'imaginez en
entreprise le jour où vous supprimez une
donnée cruciale on saura vous vous
retrouver ce qui participe quelque part
à à aussi à cette cette explosion des
données je le rappelle le cycle de la
donnée pour pour ceux qui l'ont en tête
il ne s'arrête pas à la production ni au
stockage des données mais il va
normalement jusqu'à sa suppression sauf
si on arrive à à justifier sa
réutilisation et là on tombe dans le
rgpd et ce que j'aurais bien voulu avoir
de d'information de votre part c'est à
l'air du du Big Data et du dat Lake bien
évidemment l'IA et le quantique vont
nous permettre de traiter des données
toujours plus importantes mais est-ce
qu'il ne serait pas utile de de se
mettre au régime des maintenant car
quelque part dans vos fonctions
respectives il est toujours plus simple
d'être efficace est précis sur des
qualités données maîtrisables que sur
des données qu'on ne maîtrise pas voilà
donc comment dans les fonctions qui sont
les vôres j'i ma question pensez-vous
messieurs pouvoir juguler cette fuite en
avant si tentit qu'on puisse la juguler
et je suis bien conscient qu'elle est
vous l'avez dit Monsieur le Secrétaire
général elle est forcément liée à
l'exposion de la démographie et au fait
que chacun dans le
monde acquière chaque année des
appareils connectés qui eux produisent
de la
donné je rappelle juste chers collègues
que si tout le monde veut parler il
faudrait qu'on se contente d'une
question et d'une minute merci
beaucoup je vais je vais essayer de de
répondre vite et de passer lesment sur
les aspects réglementaires et sur les
aspects législatifs je relisais il y a
pas longtemps les textes je la loi de
1881 29 juillet 1881 sur la presse il y
a tout déjà dedans il y a tout déjà
dedans notamment identifier qui écrit
qui publie et qui édite
et ce qui est écrit et oublié doit
respecter les lois en vigueur et en tout
cas ne pas nuire à la paix publique et
depuis on a toujours été là-dessus et la
loi que vous avez voté en 2018 elle va
un peu sur ce ce même point après il
faut sans doute améliorer un certain
nombre de choses par exemple la capacité
que nous pouvons avoir à aller chercher
des données et donc le caséchamp pouvoir
pénétrer dans les données lorsque vous
avez voté la LPM on vous a proposer
plusieurs articles qui permettaient
d'aller placer des marqueurs dans
certains faveur de pouvoir chercher
quelques données pour regarder s'il y
avait pas des intrus et
euh pouvoir maîtriser ses attaques sur
ce sujet donc nous avons déjà grâce à
vous pu renforcer un peu notre action
sur ce sujet il faudra que nous
puissions regarder si effectivement
compte tenu de l'évolution des temps et
notamment avec l'irruption de
l'intelligence artificielle et du
quantique nous n'avons pas besoin
d'avoir d'autres éléments très
techniques mais alors là je suis
complètement dépassé donc je vais passer
avec soulagement le relais à mes voisins
pour pour évoquer ce sujet le le seul
point que je peux dire en tout cas sur
l'intelligence artificielle et le
quantique c'est que c'est à la fois une
menace parce que ça peut permettre des
dérèglements dans tous les sens mais
c'est aussi un atout parce que ça nous
permettre ça peut nous permettre aussi
de déceler plus facilement des fake news
des attaques et et et pour pouvoir
intervenir et et donc dans ce domaine il
faudra que nous puissions à l'avir à la
fois avoir euh des règles qui soient
strict mais aussi nous servir de ces
outils comme des outils permettant de
protéger la liberté la liberté d'opinion
et la liberté d'expression et je vous
passe le
rel le alors concernant le
l'intelligence
artificielle effectivement pour nous ça
c'est ça ça emporte trois trois défis
principaux le premier c'est
effectivement est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle demain va permettre de
mener plus facilement des attaques
informatiques le constat que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est que ce n'est
pas encore le cas voil on n pas trouvé
d'attaque informatique qui avait été
généré par unea bon aujourd'hui est-ce
que demain ce sera le cas je ne pe pas
vous le dire le deuxième défi que ça que
ça nous pose c'est effectivement comment
protéger ces intelligences artificielles
il y a une vraie question de vous savez
protéger les algorithmes faire en sorte
que ces intelligences artificielles
continuent à fonctionner comme elles ont
été entraînées et qu'elle ne produise
pas des résultats qui seraient aberrants
ou biaisés quoi donc ça c'est un sujet
très difficile sur lequel nous n'avons
pas très honnêtement les idées claires
parce que ça touche à des questions de
presque de recherche quoi donc c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous allons investir
dans les années qui viennent mais
aujourd'hui je peux pas vous donner
vraiment de d'indications très claires
et puis le troisième sujet c'est
effectivement comment utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle pour mieux
se protéger donc ça effectivement c'est
un outil très utile euh que nous
utilisons déjà hein puisque vous le
savez ça rejoint la question sur
l'explosion des données
euh pour faire une bonne cybersécurité
effectivement il faut collecter des
données techniques qui sont pas des
données euh identifiantes qui ne sont
pas des données sur les contenus mais
bien des données techniqu euh pour
savoir s'il n'y a pas eu des
comportements anormaux qui euh seraient
euh des signes précurseurs d'une attaque
informatique donc nous avons besoin de
collecter énormément de données et nous
en collectons de plus en plus sous le
contrôle de l'arcepcep évidemment
et un contrôle qui a été renforcé par la
dernière loi de programmation militaire
pour s'assurer que évidemment on ne fait
pas n'importe quoi avec ces données
c'est c'est une bonne chose mais voilà
nous avons aussi beaucoup de données et
donc l'intelligence artificielle
finalement c'est un outil qui va nous
permettre de trouver ben cette aiguille
dans une botte de foin et qui nous
permettra de dire là il y a un début
d'attaque informatique qui mériterait
d'être
investigué monsieur président peut-être
juste plusieurs complément donc
notamment sur les propos du secrétaire
général s'agissant de la loi de 2018
donc je sais qu' est actuellement
débattu le projet de loi Seren donc qui
renforce un certain nombre de
d'obligations il y a la mise en œuvre
future du digital service Act qui a crée
de nouvelles obligation à l'égard
notamment des opérateurs de plateforme
en ligne donc je pense que l'enjeu pour
nous aujourd'hui il est avantage de voir
pendant un temps l'articulation entre
ces différents dispositifs et de voir si
d'éventuelles modifications législatives
peuvent être demandées j'ai j'aime
beaucoup l'axe du DSA et du projet SRN
c'est-à-dire que ce qui est illégal dans
la vie réelle doit l'être aussi dans la
vie numérique je pense que ça c'est un
axe qui me paraît important s'agissant
de l'intelligence artificielle et pour
répondre à la question qui qui a été
faite je rejoint parfaitement ce qui a
été dit tant par le général nelen que le
secrétaire général c'est-à-dire que
certes on voit aujourd'hui de nouvelles
menaces qui pourraient poindre par
l'utilisation l'intelligence artifici
notamment des modèles génératifs que ce
soit par exemple en animation de faux
compte et d'Avatar de façon beaucoup
plus file en génération de contenu de
qualité et donc qui pourrait passer en
dessous des seuils de détection des
plateformes ou éventuellement dans la
diffusion massive de données pour
saturer un débat public ça c'est des
menaces réelles mais en face en tant que
bouclier l'intelligence artificielle
nous est utile pour renforcer nos
capacités de détection aujourd'hui on
peut imaginer des projets avec certaines
structures pour développer des outils de
détection de Deep fake donc de vidéos
fabriqué par l'intelligence artificielle
C donc je pense que c'est autant un
usage pour le glev un usage pour le
bouclier que nous sommes et et sur ce
sujet-là nous avons déjà des travaux en
cours pour permettre d'améliorer nos
capacités de
détection si oui tu avais un petit mot
rapide sur ce point pour aller dans dans
votre sens la semaine dernière donc le
Chief de l'intelligence artificielle
chez Facebook le groupe ma disait que en
2017 lors de la campagne présidentielle
ils arrivaient à supprimer 20 à 25 % des
discours de haine grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle en 2017 aujourd'hui ils en
sont à 95,6 % pour ça pour aller dans
votre
sens merci merci Olivier la question la
pardon la parole à Patrice
jolie merci Monsieur le le président
monsieur le secrétaire général ma
question pose portera sur la menace à la
menace je m'explique vous avez euh
évoquer tous les dispositifs défensifs
que vous mettez en place jeis savoir si
vous avez également une mission
offensive c'est-à-dire
comment éventuellement nous agissons
pour dans le cadre des valeurs et que
que nous portons bien évidemment pour
soutenir les mouvements démocratiques
des pays qui qui nous attaquent et pour
relever informer dénoncer la
manipulation la maltraitance de la
population concernée à destination de
cette population je vous remercie
merci et Roger
carucci oui moi c'est un petit peu
différent Monsieur le Secrétaire général
un de vos propos introductifs m'a
interpellé à un moment vous avez dit le
bloc autant
Occident il faut pas qu'on tombe dans le
piège que nous tendent les ennemis de ce
bloc en essayant de faire une
confrontation entre autant Occident et
entre guillemets les ennemis de ce bloc
j'avais plutôt que comprendre que dans
le rapport de force
la Chine la Russie l'Iran la Turquie
effectivement rentrer dans un bloc
antioccident mais c'était pas
spécialement un piège c'était un nouveau
rapport de force est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire qu'est-ce que vous appelez le
piège je vous laisse répondre et après
j'aurai une question
oui d'abord peut-être pour pour le
sénateur jolie la la difficulté de la
désinformation c'est que c'est une
menace totalement asymétrique dans nos
démocraties euh s'il y a une attaque
cyberè dans un transport en commun
immédiatement le président de la RATP le
ministre sont convoqués interrogés on se
demande pourquoi ils ont pas fait les
chosees dans tel ou tel capitale que je
ne citerai pas s'il y a une panne de
métro on va considérer que c'est normal
et de toute façon personne n'osera poser
la question de savoir pourquoi elle
s'est produite et quand est-ce que ça va
repartir parce que finalement ça arrive
assez souvent en matière de manipulation
de l'information c'est la même chose il
y a pas de liberté de presse donc il est
absolument impossible de pouvoir
communiquer vers ces différents état
nous essayons malgré tout de le faire
puisque le dispositif France 24 le
dispositif RFI sont des dispositifs
d'information qui passe soit par les
ondes soit par internet et qui
permettent d'assurer une forme
d'information vers vers le grand
public après je sors si je peux dire de
mon domaine de compétences le SGDSN il a
pour objectif de protéger euh d'être le
bouclier encore une fois pas d'être
l'épée nous sommes en contact avec
l'épée euh et et à la limite puisque
vous voyez madame Colona cet après-midi
je pense que vous pourrez lui poser la
question puisqu'elle a mis en place une
stratégie d'influence euh avec le
ministère des armées qui vise à faire
passer un certain nombre d'éléments
d'information non seulement sur la
politique que nous menons mais sur les
actions que nous menons mais également
pour essayer de de jouer notre rôle en
matière un peu plus d'épée donc voilà ce
que je peux vous dire sur ce sujet mais
cl très clairement en tout cas on est
dans une menace asymétrique nous n'avons
pas par définition puisque nous sommes
une démocratie et que nous sommes
confrontés à certains pays qui ne le
sont pas nous avons du mal à pouvoir
faire passer des éléments d'information
sur ce
sujet le le piège monsieur le sénateur
carucci du wouest G
verest c'est que l'expression elle a été
inventée si je puux dire par euh un ou
deux des pays que vous venez de citer
nous nous ne l'avions pas en tête et
nous considérons hier j'étais à l'UTAN
nous considérons quand nous travaillons
avec nos partenaires avec l'ensemble des
démocraties que nous avons un rôle de
soutien de développement de partage de
nos valeurs d'extension de nos valeurs à
faire
passer ce qui s'est produit c'est que
certains autres pays essaient au
contraire de dire c'est complètement
dépassé la démocratie c'est pas un bon
système pour l'ensemble des nations qui
peuvent exister sur la planète et de
toute façon les Occidentaux ne sont qu'
des néocoloniaux qui veulent garder leur
pouvoir leur emprise et cetera et cetera
c'est ça le piège dans lequel il faut
que nous évis de tomber et donc dans
l'ensemble des politiques que nous
menons avec l'OTAN il y aura un sommet
en juillet dans l'ensemble des actions
que nous menons à travers le G7 à
travers l'ensemble des actions que nous
menons sur le plan diplomatique y
compris avec les uns et les autres nous
devons justement faire en sorte qu'un
certain nombre de pays ne tombe pas dans
ce piège et ne nous range pas dans une
catégorie au profit de ceux qui
voudraient en créer une autre qui de
fait n'existe pas parce que de reste on
voit bien la la différence des attitudes
entre les uns et les autres
mais ça n'est pas nous qui avons inventé
l'expression ce sont nos adversaire et
s'ils l'ont inventé c'est pas pour nous
rendre
service merci Monsieur le Directeur
euh si on a terminé avec les questions
moi je je je j'aurais une petite
question à formuler parce que
j'attendais de voir si mes collègues
allaient en parler au préalable pour
leur laisser la possibilité de le faire
euh il y a plusieurs points moi je je
suis étonné effectivement comme comme
Michell parfois que la question des
punaises de lit pour les Jeux Olympiques
même si c'est une menace évidemment
qu'il faut pas négliger soit plus
importante pour certains que la
problématique de notre capacité à être
opérationnelle en matière de lutte
anti-drô par exemple mais ça peut-être
aurons-nous l'occasion d'en parler
ultérieurement Monsieur le Secrétaire
général j'auraai une question vous savez
que je suis particulièrement inquet sur
un certain nombre de points et notamment
sur la projet le projet de de cission
d'Atos et le projet de scission d'Atos
il soulève évidemment de très nombreuses
interrogations tant sur les conséquences
pour la souveraineté nationale bien
évidemment d'une vente à un investisseur
étranger que des questions concernant
évidemment la cyber et d'autres sujets
particulièrement stratégiques et de ce
fait un certain nombre d'acteurs d'Atos
et de salariés d'Atos sont détenteurs de
très
nombreux j'allais dire habilitation en
matière de secret défense euh et donc
vous le savez cette opération je la suis
avec un certain nombre de collègues
depuis le début du mois d'août mais
aussi depuis bien avant de manière très
précise et j'aurais souhaité savoir
Monsieur le Secrétaire général quel
était le rôle et les moyens d'action qui
sont
mis à votre disposition dans cette
délicate affaire dans laquelle je trouve
cette avis très personnel on a très peu
entendu finalement en tout cas
publiquement euh les services concernés
sur des questions qui concerne quand
même la sécurité nationale notre
capacité à à à de lutte en matière cyber
les Jeux Olympiques dans laquelle atos
est quand même particulièrement impliqué
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire et une
des questions une des réponses qu'on
peut peut-être formuler à Michel Valet
sur son interrogation concernant les
moyens qu'on met à disposition de vos
service pour les Jeux Olympiques c'est
peut-être aussi celle qu'on a délégué à
Athos avec des conséquences
potentiellement euh critique euh voilà
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
un mot il y a évidemment la question des
super calculateurs et et beaucoup
d'autres mais la question essentielle
c'est se de la sécurité nationale qui
quand même est largement prise en compte
par Atos avec les conséquences que ça
peut avoir aujourd'hui
merci je j'aurais je vous l'avoue un peu
de mal à répondre complètement à votre
question monsieur le Président
euh mais je ne manquerai pas de la
relayer à l'ensemble des interlocuteurs
avec qui je suis amené à avoir des
réunions de travail sur ce sujet et euh
à à travailler sur l'avenir le rôle du
SGDSN vous l'avez rappelé sur ce sujet
c'est que
Atos nous aide en matière de
cybersécurité pour les JO et l'any a eu
un rôle non négligeable pour faire en
sorte que le rgpd soit respecté par les
prestateurs des services informatiques
pour les JO donc pas celui qui était
prévu par le CIO mais du coup un
prestateur français euh donc
Atos ils ont été les acteurs majeurs
dans les Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo oui
oui tout à fait parpr pas que
VO et et deuxièmement nous sommes
évidemment très sensibles au super
calculateurs qui sont indispensables
pour notre dissuasion nucléaire sans
compter un bon nombre d'autres services
en matière d'informatique donc le rôle
du SGDSN dans ce dans cette situation
c'est de rappeler un peu comme vous
venez de le faire que nous avons des
intérêts fondamentaux et que la solution
qui doit être trouvé pour l'avenir
d'Atos doit intégrer nécessairement la
protection et la capacité d'Atos ou des
nouvelles entreprises ou de la nouvelle
entreprise qui lui qui lui succédera de
préserver intégralement notre
souveraineté et notre capacité
d'innovation d'intelligence et de
production de systèmes informatique
performant et de calculateurs également
performant pour notre dissuasion je
désolé je peux pas vous en dire plus sur
ce thème mais j'ai bien pris le message
oui oui je pense que le message circule
depuis un certain temps et puis je vous
je veux rappeler puisquon est capté
aussi que on on réfléchit quand même
très très sérieusement cont enfin en
fonction de de la manière dont les
choses se dérouleront puisque là les
choses on ont un peu bougé mais de
mettre en œuvre une commission d'enquête
dans cette commission sur ce sujet donc
on observe très attentivement ce qui se
passe Monsieur le Secrétaire général
monsieur mon Général Monsieur le Chef de
Service merci beaucoup pour vos votre
intervention vos interventions et
surtout la sincérité euh d'un certain
nombre de vos propos alors pas sur Atos
mais ça je peux comprendre que ce soit
compliqué et de la caractérisation
notamment d'un certain nombre de menaces
que vous avez clairement décrite qui
jusqu'à présent était connu mais peu
caractérisé donc je voudrais vous
remercier pour votre sincérité et puis
cette audition compenu évidemment des
menaces et des enjeux mondiaux que nous
constatons tous quotidiennement en
appellera beaucoup d'autres vous avez
beaucoup parlé du bouclier et peu de
l'épée ce sera peut-être l'occasion de
faire des auditions peut-être un peu
moins filmées euh mais qui vous permett
permettront de nous donner davantage
d'informations en tout cas merci pour
votre vos interventions et puis bonne
journée je par rappelle à mes collègues
que nous avons un certain nombre de
sujets encore à traiter donc ne partez
pas merci
beaucoup